but you know we we have been so  conditioned and programmed especially  this day and age of the rise of  Technology  we think we're so advanced because we  have all of these gadgets you know right  but I would ask more that this is  actually a reaction or expression of  externalizing technology because we have  removed we have this is the connected or  have purposely disconnect from our own  body technology in a technology in terms  of powers we have you can manipulate  reality and and you know move up you  know like through states of  consciousness we cannot even possibly  imagine right now so we're more more  dependent of our the technology and if  you see it how the world the culture and  the matrix works it makes us even more  dependent of it all to remove to get us  out of body even more until be merged  with machine and that's